the storm could not be coming at a worse
time for florida where resources are
already stretched thin
amid a surge of coronavirus cases our
lead national correspondent david begno
is in miami
david can the state handle another
crisis right now
oh look they'll tell you they can but
i'm reminded what the head of the
emergency management agency said to me
four weeks ago
we are spending as many resources on
this pandemic as we would normally spend
on a category five hurricane
now you just heard lonnie the projection
as of now looks good
but florida is preparing for a potential
landfall just in case that storm
starts to move we do expect to see
impacts to the state of florida the
state of florida's coronavirus response
now includes managing a potential
hurricane
at the gladiolus food pantry in fort
myers florida
the executive director is worried about
the strain the virus
is already putting on resources people
are not prepared not for the pandemic
i don't even know how we're going to
prepare if we have a reckon coming
capacity is also a concern at
miami-dade's hard-hit hospitals
dr david delazerta runs an icu at
jackson memorial hospital
if it's a big storm and you have sick
people or injured people we will have an
issue where to actually put all these
patients
what's the situation in the icu's right
now so when i see you start completely
full
very young and sick patients florida
recorded a new high for coronavirus
deaths for the third consecutive day
arizona and mississippi also reported
record-breaking increases
and average daily deaths are rising in
at least 17 states nationwide
and as millions of americans apply for
unemployment every week
some states are struggling to provide
that assistance
many of the people my district have had
no income no
income since march
in california the unemployment
development department is backlogged so
they haven't paid out more than
a million unemployment claims you can
start as early as six in the morning
and be on the phone twelve hours linda
margolin
says she's waited six weeks for her
unemployment check
right now they probably owe me close to
five thousand dollars
i've received one benefit
look when we think about parents getting
back to work we have to think about the
children
there is new data from the journal of
the american medical association
which says young kids who are infected
may have as much virus in their nose and
mouth
as us adults do now remember most kids
do not suffer from severe symptoms
and it's unclear if having that much in
their nose and mouth actually affects
their ability
to spread it to other people gail as
we've said we continue to say
the doctors are still learning and so
are we
i know this nobody wants to take any
chances with their children but to think
about
covid and a possible hurricane david
it's just too much
thank you very much